hola que tal lamentable esta situación
lo último que se conoce es que daría el
y sarabia la madre de este pequeño que
murió por la acción de la guardia
costera de trinidad y tobago se
encuentra estable ella está recluida en
el hospital sangre grande de trinidad y
sus familiares están a la espera de que
su otra hija de cuatro años de edad sea
entregada pues ella se encuentra junto
con los otros 17 pasajeros de esta
embarcación detenida o retenida en el
helipuerto militar de chaguaramas e
interinidad y 7 m que podrían ser
deportados las organizaciones no
gubernamentales que han estado al
pendiente de este caso entre ellas el
foro penal venezolano
exhorta a que estas personas no sean
deportadas pues aseguran que han huido
por las precarias condiciones en las que
se encuentran en venezuela y por eso es
riesgo en sus vidas intentando buscar un
mejor futuro sin embargo hasta el
momento se desconoce cuál sería la
acción que va a tomar el gobierno de
trinidad y tobago conversando también
con orlando moreno quien es el
coordinador de esta ong foro penal
venezolano en delta amacuro
aseguraba que son de entre 6 y 10
embarcaciones diarias que parten desde
esta entidad en el oriente venezolano
rumbo a trinidad y tobago por lo que
asegura son miles las personas que huyen
del país por la situación en la que se
encuentra bueno y brevemente vemos que
hay pronunciamientos de parte de la
oposición juan guaidó escribió en su
cuenta de 'twitter' que no hay
justificación para asesinar al menor y
pide justicia hay más declaraciones del
gobierno de maduro ya se pronuncia
no hay numerosos pronunciamientos por
parte de diputados de la asamblea
nacional líderes opositores
organizaciones no gubernamentales pero
hasta el momento no ha habido un
pronunciamiento por parte de la
administración de nicolás maduro ni a
través de las redes sociales ni siquiera
de la cancillería pero pudimos conocer
por un comunicado del primer ministro de
trinidad y tobago que él dijo que había
conversado directamente con la
vicepresidenta del psir rodríguez y que
ella le había asegurado que se iban a
acelerar el proceso para las
credenciales del nuevo embajador de
terminal tobago que llegó a venezuela el
viernes para que hubiese una mejor
comunicación y cooperación entre ambos
países para atender estas situaciones lo
único que se conoce por parte del
gobierno venezolano